well president trump is expected to
announce as early as
next week that coalition forces have
reclaimed
all of the territory once held by isis
in syria
mr trump has said the u.s will not
immediately pull its troops out of syria
even as isis forces and their families
are on the run charlie dagetta reports
now from
inside syria huddled against the cold on
a rocky desert floor the families and
suspected fighters
who fled the last village under isis
control
eating american-made rations and living
out of a hole in the ground
isis fighters have been caught trying to
sneak out with their families
yet all of the men we spoke with denied
being members of the terror
group were you an isis fighter no no
hassan salah told us
insisting he only sold sweets so what
did you do
this man said he was a simple food
seller you don't look very well
are you sick were you injured in
fighting no no i was tortured by isis
for texting my
uncle amar ahmed told us he said they
were frightened to leave
because isis would punish anyone trying
to escape
it's hard to know who's telling the
truth here now we're under strict
instructions not to point our camera in
that direction
but around 100 yards away we found u.s
and coalition special forces
who are part of the vital process to
weed out
and take away any isis suspects
they have fled by the thousands in
recent weeks as u.s
forces and allies here tighten the noose
on the last sliver of territory under
isis control
anirajang one woman told us that her
husband had been killed in an
air strike and in the end she had
nothing to feed her three
children but grass the suffering finally
reached a point
that survival alone became the only
option
left for cbs this morning saturday
charlie dagetta in eastern syria
some great reporting by charlie